charles pasqua a justifié aujourd'hui
devant les journalistes cette mesure
d'expulsion et a tenu ensuite à
commenter ce climat social c'est la
faute dit-il des socialistes le problème
c'est pas celui du sehy p&c ça c'est pas
le problème ça on peut naturellement
toujours essayé de monter les choses en
épingle c'est été mal présentée tout ce
que vous voudrez mais c'est pas le
problème le problème c'est de savoir si
dans les dix ans qui viennent on sera
capable réformer profondément l'état et
la société pour que chacun ait sa chance
c'est bien que le problème c'est la
concentration dans les banlieues la
désertification du reste de la france la
montée des inégalités
je n'ai pas eu de mots assez durs le
premier ministre aussi et c'est quand on
aime les gouvernements précédents qui
nous ont laissé cette situation je suis
pas en train de faire de la politique
politicienne
je constate